on dit souvent que dans un couple tant
que tout va bien au lit tout va bien
dans la vie mais le sexe est il vraiment
un thermomètre du couple vos questions à
nos questions avec le confinement et le
télétravail imposé à des millions de
français
nombreux sont les couples qui sont
restés ensemble 24 heures sur 24
une proximité qui on imagine peut donner
des idées et rapprocher les corps on
gronde
parce que tu es belle pourtant selon une
étude ce ne serait pas du tout le cas
c'est ce que dit un sondage ifop qui
indique que 44% des français n'aurait eu
aucun rapport sexuel pendant le premier
confinement 18 % de plus qu hors
périodes de confinement un chiffre qui
nous montre à quel point les français ne
font pas l'amour à se demander pourquoi
ce sont toujours nos voisins qui comme
par hasard font crac crac juste derrière
le mur en carton de notre appart
alors selon vous le sexe doit-il être la
priorité d'un couple aïssa qui est là
aïssa écoute moi rien ça aïe ça qu'est
ce que vous êtes
ça c'est que ça dans les sentiers je
vais réussir cette manif
[Musique]
doit-il être primordial pour un coup
parce que alors on va rester bien sûr
très famille alain et façon je veux dire
on va parler de ça mais dans une
ambiance familiale bon goût les lasers
bon goût regarder aïe ça c'est la classe
donc aïssa il paraît que le concevoir
mais beaucoup de mal aux couples
exactement qu'est ce qui s'est passé bah
écoute les gens ont du mal à se
rapprocher ont du mal à se retrouver
du coup quand on est enfermé dans une
dans un appartement avec ton conjoint
que t'as pas l'habitude de voir tous les
jours parce que je peux te tutoyer tu
peux tout faire
radio a tant au niveau physique mais
moundir koh lanta et une favela tu peux
arriver sur le plateau
reste un autre achat latrous a ouï dire
non mais c'est vrai que tu sais quand tu
es en couple avec quelqu'un je ne vois
pas tous les jours en général ross andy
sociale etc
le fait d'avoir le confinement 7 mars et
le voir tous les jours et donc ça crime
dynamique qui n'est pas qui est pas
bonne habituel et qui est pas ça se
moquerait le monde banque tient pas il
ya plus de manque donc ton conjoint
devient un peu ton colocataires c'est ça
parce que tu vois tous les jours quand
tu rentres dans les dents les voilà tu
le vois oui encore dégueulasse on n'est
plus dans la séduction assez salée chez
l'esthéticienne on peut plus se préparer
on peut plus sécurité et puis way et
puis quand on travaille on est content
de retrouver la personne qu'on aime
c'est vrai je ne savais pas c'est une
longue journée on a envie de souffler
sauf que là la personne qu'on aime et à
côté toujours avant que c'est de tout
faire soi même
moi par exemple voilà je sais que j'ai
des potes ils ont essayé de se raser
intégralement pas forcément ils ont fait
ça la tondeuse
r j'avais un côté la cave et un espèce
de voile à d'une barbe de trois jours la
loi découle ici tu as désormais sans
rigoler laïcité dans mais c'est une de
ses salles à huy est ce que vous
confirmez parce que j'ai lu une étude
très intéressante de keynes et institute
qui disait que non le confinement
on avait fait moi l'amour on avait fait
mieux l'amour c'est à dire que justement
on avait pensé à ses fantasmes on avait
utilisé des objets on avait fait des
positions différentes
est ce que on était plus que ça comme
allemand mais moins et l'autre étaient
là mais l'émission branco les croire
d'accord les statistiques
ouais j'y mal ay croire d'accord je
pense que après moi je vais je vais me
baser uniquement sur les gens que j'ai
en eau en coaching mon expert mandaté
par le phénomène
j'ai pas parlé de moi j'ai parlé de mes
clients alors parce que c'est pour
raymond que pose la question de rigoler
il a pris une claque dans la gueule
non mais t'as tellement belle je croyais
à la haye a tout essayé la voie vous
êtes ben c'est un truc perso ou vrai je
suis travesti donc vous dis-je et moi
j'y crois pas trop pourquoi parce que je
pense que les gens ont fait beaucoup de
bébés restent y lisons ce jeudi les
bébés moi j'ai connu mais à la fin tout
seul à appeler jean jacques goldman non
c'est que non c'est que les les gens ont
du mal à vraiment se retrouver avec
l'autre c'est difficile donc parfois on
a l'impression qu'on connait son
conjoint son partenaire en fait on le
connaît pas vraiment souvent je vais
vous dire et on sait ce qui se passe
quand on est enfermé
on se rencontre que l'autre est
quelqu'un dont elle est une seule autre
n'est pas celui qu'on la croyait
victimes non mais c'est vrai l'autre
avec un grand a
quand le redécouvre comme adversaire
aborigènes un autre qui dit l'autre
c'est moi non exactement bienvenue
l'affairé des maillets 10 et l'autre
c'est moi et moi j'ai toujours dit
l'autre celle où vous vouliez la giraude
rires oui selon une étude à une baisse
de libido chez français qu'est ce que
vous en personne c'est dû à quoi c'est
dû à leur moral qui est un peu en berne
chamboulé sais quoi et moi je pense que
les gens pensent que la libido c'est
uniquement tout ce qui est lié au
rapport physique qui s'était ras tout ce
qui éveille les sens
or pour moi la libido c'est ce qui a
aussi à l'extérieur chez d'autres
personnes que ça maintenant
[Rires]
c'est bon t'es à l'extérieur d'abord
joue à domicile et parfois que je vous
dois d'être là si mais c'est à
l'extérieur dans le sens où il faut
qu'il y ait une dynamique
tu vas y à pas dynamique c'est-à-dire
qui a pas de vie sociale en plus ya le
stress qui joue avec henri vide tu as
des problèmes professionnels tu as tes
problèmes financiers raison là les
enfants
imagine toi tu es bloquer la fois on
pense pas ça comme tu as pu en 6e
c'était maintenant t'as plus envie d'en
bas et vidéos effectivement la grèce a
justement visiblement un sondage ifop
qui vient de sortir et qui disent que
les gens veulent justement appréhender
ce confinement d'une autre manière
le deuxième c'est sur dix lancements ont
transgressé les règles dans confinement
afin d'avoir des rapports sexuels dont
est aussi aline les sex-shops ont été
dévalisés riz en une journée ils ont
doublé leur chiffre d'affaires pour
acheter des objets coquins de la
lingerie des produits en titane et ça
c'est martine aubry c'est la base
à lissue de comme il peut te dire à
lille martine aubry semblait allait déjà
l'aéroport ya des sections martine aubry
sa connaissance oui possible les
limitations déplacement moi j'ai un pote
on sait plus du tout sa gueule pendant
cinq ans parce qu'il est plein n'était
pas véhiculés sur tous les terrains même
les jamais prendre un taxi pour aller
sur des plans des jo qui trouvait sur
sur steam des choses comme ça et du coup
il s'est fait un réseau de 4 5 9 des
plans réguler à un kilomètre de chez lui
y aller à pied avec le confinement ce qu
il nous a tous grillés parce que vit
avec 4 5 modes de cette réunion où ils
avaient droit à sa revanche à lui il a
fait encore mieux mais il s'est marié
4,5
c'est un jour à foyer s'appelle je suis
sûr qu'il ya des jeux des jeux à faire
également
quand je vous dis des jeux c'est pas
monopoly qui va nous exciter un c'est
pas un docteur maboule du mexique 1-1
scrabble qu'aucun asca bonne qu aucun
sac avec des mots un genre un peu oui
quoi vous croyez vraiment géotop ou non
mais c'est vrai les délais d un double
nom hines à alice al adib réjouis
lesquels equalia sexothérapeute ou
sexologue à l'habitude beaucoup
d'aventurés est la lutte depuis que la
connecte sans regret a dit connaître
deux mecs avaient c'est le calme plat
ces trois jours vous la connaissez
mais disons que la connaît oui dix ans
vous dire c'est pas le câble plat quand
ça se réveille pour vous lire pourquoi
dans les plats on vous le dira si c'est
là où elle a tort c'est qu'en fait les
gens se sont rattrapés par rapport au
premier confinement oui donc pour le
deuxième ils ont mis les bouchées
doubles pour à la réactiver l'activité
ces clans qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent vraiment rr qui vais tout ça
pour vraiment voilà qu'on se dise
arriver là où la boue c'est à dire avec
sa personne par exemple voilà il ya un
truc tout con
vraiment je vous le dit chez vous
vraiment par exemple ça on évite
barça on est vite s'arrêter comme on
adore mon et c'est vraiment le confignon
plus le gars carré comme ça là c'est sûr
que là sans faire directement dans la
salle de bal à ses chats ni j'en ai déjà
vu assez il a fait assez de mal comme ça
les petites astuces
oui les devils vainqueurs à risque ou
des magic l'aider mais le déménagement
alors le des matches c'est quoi le des
magic le dés magiques en fait ça
consiste à faire de liste alors une
liste pour les membres du corps donc où
le coup la tête et pied le salon met pas
la tête on prend le demos et ensuite
nous on fait une deuxième liste ee en
mai les actions non c'est à dire les ché
le coude mais c'est pas moi c'est
terminé les chais mort etc
l'agente l'aider à prouver genre le goût
de le genou c'est très concret c'est
très con comme aqua 2 a du mal à avoir
de joutes à dallas
les parties du jeu ah oui quand tu
jettes l'aider bon si tu es assez
ingénieux tue mais voilà tu mets des
choses assez car j'aurai de quoi la
femme de castaldi va pas m voir ma
poitrine très bientôt il va pas l'avoir
voilà c'était le truc c'est en fonction
ce conte et tiens en parlant
voilà vous écouter daniel passé
religieusement religieusement est ce qu
est ce que vous j'avais été touché par a
oui moi je normes pression sociale à
cause des films à cause du porno etc qui
sous-entend que pour être heureux en
couple il faut avoir des relations
sexuelles tout le temps oui on peut être
amoureux de quelqu'un
berkshire ne jamais avoir de relations
sexuelles ou surtout avoir une vie
sexuelle moyenne c'est pas indispensable
d'avoir une vie sexuelle de ouf pas
d'être heureux vous allez être bifurquer
aujourd'hui il ya plein de gens qui ont
pas eu de relations sexuelles pendant
confinement c'est maintenant grave on a
su regarder avec laniel ça fait quarante
savanes a fait les cons finale attendue
le corollaire vient de créer le manque
dans un couple je voulais m'adresser aux
derniers qui m'a dit ça il fallait créer
le manque dans un couple ça fait 25 ans
il n'est jamais revenu
c'est bon le manque maintenant je
mettrais
chapeau style les bons vous comment ça
se passe mais surtout qu'elle s'adonne
pas trop d'idées un parce que moi ça me
va très bien notre rythme lent alors
aïssa ses conseils à donner à nos
téléspectateurs
parce que la shoah ça réagit énormément
il faut se laver aussi parce que pendant
le court même avait bien un truc qui est
super bien ça s'appelle l'ivresse des
saveurs l'ivresse de saveur alors donc
tu prends du miel de la gentille du
nutella du cousinage en ald et mieux je
suis prêt oui c'est pourquoi pas
connaître ou couscous tout ça veut un
avion on comprend du miel ceci est
sifflé à chantilly voilà est en fait tu
vas banlieue sur le gâteau c'est à dire
entre la champagne et la merguez tu as
plutôt molle et la chantilly le jeu
terrible et je sais que tu bandes
rivales faire t'inquiète pas dans votre
mémoire si c'est dégueulasse tel
qu'annoncé m'a présenté je te prends
comme elle dérange pas c'est quand on
est beau gosse ça je te crois comme
exemple ah bah oui voilà ok tu mets un
bandeau ouais haute sur tes yeux
je ne vois rien d'accord ok y'a une
femme ou un homme suit pas
comme ça pas comme ça oui alors voilà et
cette personne elle se met de la
chantilly non pas quand sur le corps toi
tu dois faire en sorte de remédier à la
transformer en bas là l'aspect non on a
tous un petit peu dans ce jeu va trouver
parce que tu as les yeux bandés d'accord
où se trouve la chantilly à imola
personnes regrettent en lingerie au
moins au moins au minimum en avril il
faut plaire personnel soit l'âge
d'accord et donc là je cherches tu
cherches et donc elle me dit la
chantilly plus à droite plus à gauche on
pas du tout tu te débrouilles merci
vraiment génial j'ai fait ça avec du
miel ça attire les mites alimentaires
sont elles à la fin un jeu sexuel avec
son mari s'était mis de la chantilly ils
ont eu des messieurs la voyons s'est
écroulé dell pas possible il ya une
autre truc aussi ce1 chéquier le
chéquier de cupidon c'est quoi ça
servait vous syrie c'était ma bande les
yeux et tu ne vois pas mes yeux je fais
des check
on va plutôt vers la sortie c'est
plusieurs gages en fait c'est légal
sexuelle une fois que tu as un rôle
belga je sais pas a relevé le défi ont
déchiré le chèque et puis on le sait
quoi une sorte de gage passé à peine un
peu trash voilà exactement parfois là ça
peut être essayer d'avoir un rapport
sexuel dans un avion à l'extérieur de le
faire d'accord j'ai quand même pas le
chercher
merci